ine les travaux de l'assemblée nationale
cet après-midi le remboursement de l'ibg
c'est un peu si vous voulez la seconde
bataille de l'avortement
mais cette fois-ci l'hémicycle était
bien vide des comptes rendus des séances
daniel brême
jean louis lahaye celle de lundi à
vendredi yvette roudy estimera sans
doute avoir beaucoup fait progresser les
droits de la femme
après l'égalité professionnelle entre
hommes et femmes c'était cet après-midi
le remboursement d'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans une
ambiance terne de fin de semaine et le
rapporteur était une femme en tant que
médecin et mère de six enfants
je vous affirme qu'aucune femme dans
l'obligation d'interrompre sa grossesse
le fait de gaieté à la légère sans
réfléchir
oui le remboursement à tana de justice
sociale non il ne balise rap à
l'interruption volontaire dé grossesse
beaucoup moins de monde dans l'hémicycle
que dans les tribunes où l'élément
féminin dominer pour entendre monsieur
foyer adversaire de toujours de libé
j'ai posé la question préalable et l'a
retiré soudain après avoir profité de
l'opération pour parler 20 minutes la
république respecte toutes les croyances
dans la circonstance vous ne les
respectez points
vous violez les consciences hier le
gouvernement disait aux assemblées que
personne ne serait tenu ni pratique et
nick subi un avortement
aujourd'hui le gouvernement voudrait que
tout le monde participe financièrement à
cézac les orateurs du rpr ont beau avoir
employé un langage différent condamnant
le remboursement de l'avortement mais
pas la loi veil
c'est à monsieur foyer que le ministre
les droits de la femme a directement
répondu mais avec beaucoup de modération
la sécurité sociale pour les femmes
c'est la garantie de l'anonymat et la
faille de sécurité sociale que l'on
signe
c'est pour elle la levée d'une certaine
forme de réprobation sociale qui pèse
encore trop souvent sur un acte que les
êtres humains adultes que les femmes
sont devenues n'en déplaise à certains
un acte quel n'accomplisse jamais de
gaieté de coeur
faut-il encore le rappeler dès lors les
communistes ont prôné l'égalité devant
l'argent la justice sociale l'udf a
déploré qu'on fasse payer par l'état un
acte de mort
le rpr a condamné l'avortement acte
médical comme les autres mais en fin de
compte
le texte sera voté comme le prévoyait le
gouvernement et sa majorité